In today's video,
we are taking eggs prepared
in a variety of ways,
and putting them
to the test,
seeing how well they stay
on the freeze drying process.
[Music]
Guys, Dominic Termine
said try freeze-drying
a raw and cooked egg.
Well, I think that sounds
like an awesome idea.
But I think we can actually push
that a little bit further.
We have a lot of eggs,
and I want to try and prepare
these in a lot of strange ways,
maybe some not so strange
because eggs are
actually very well known
for freeze-drying very well
and keeping that way.
I want to push
that limit and see just
how weird we can make our eggs,
and see if they're actually
going to survive this process.
All right, we've got our freeze
dryer all ready to go.
We've got our eggs,
it's time to cook some of these.
Let's start with
a few basic eggs.
We're going to hard
boil a couple of these.
[Music]
Scrambled eggs.
That one is ready to go.
[Music]
Alright, we've got
our three types of cooked eggs.
So we're going to go ahead,
and get those set up.
Now, we're going to add
a few more to this tray.
So we've got
lots of comparisons.
Our hard boiled egg, over easy,
and some scrambled,
but I want to add a few more.
So let's go ahead and
add just a raw egg.
That's supposed to work really
well in the freeze dryer,
and I want to put
that to the test.
[Music]
Another thing I'm very curious
about is just a whole raw egg.
And last but not least,
we have got three
cooked eggs, two raw,
but I want to put
something else in there.
Now I have here a naked egg.
Now, these are so
much fun, you guys,
and you can actually
make these at home.
You'll see that this egg
doesn't have a shell anymore.
It's almost bouncy.
It's still raw,
and it still held together.
All you need to do is put
distilled white vinegar
into a cup,
and drop an egg into it
for about 24 hours.
Now what's going to happen is
the acetic acid in the vinegar
is actually going to eat
away the calcium carbonate
of the shell.
When that happens,
it starts to dissolve away.
What you end up with is an egg
that looks like this.
So you can see here,
the acetic acid actually ate
away all the calcium carbonate,
and now, you get this soft
squishy cracked shell.
If you run it under some water
and clean it up,
you get a naked egg.
Let's throw this in
with the rest of them,
get these freeze-drying.
[Music]
All right.
So we have let our eggs
freeze dry overnight,
and I'm pretty sure one
of them has exploded.
So I want to take
a look at that.
So let's turn off the machine
and see what happened.
[Music]
All right, everything
seems to have worked,
except for our vinegar egg.
It's like powdered meringue,
that is a disaster.
I want to see the footage.
I want to know
what happened there.
All right, so we
have three different angles
of the GoPros to show just
what happened here,
and I want to know,
mostly, I'm very confused
about what happened
to our vinegar egg.
There's nothing in
between those two shots.
It just explodes.
My goodness.
And then everything just
sort of shrink back down
and stays that way.
All right, what did
the other angle pick up?
We can still see
that everything's starting
to freeze and shrink up,
and this is
a two-second difference
between these two frames,
and that's insane.
That thing just exploded.
All right Dominic,
we've tried a lot
of weird things with these eggs.
So let's see what
the results are.
As you can see,
our vinegar egg was just...
It's like meringue, almost.
It's just powder.
Here's that soft rubbery shell
that was left in it.
You can see
where that split was.
These two pieces actually
stayed decently intact.
Yep, still very very
strong vinegar smell.
All right, this is awesome.
This is a freeze-dried
round egg yolk,
and it actually
feels very dense.
This is our
freeze-dried hard-boiled egg,
and it's definitely lighter
than an egg should be,
but it still feels a lot denser
than things you normally find
in a freeze dryer.
But this egg yolk that was
in our vinegar egg is solid.
Oh, that's weird.
It comes apart in layers.
No, not Center.
Whoop!
There it goes.
Freeze-dried vinegar rotten egg.
Cool.
Next up is our raw eggs.
I don't know if I can peel it,
but we're gonna try.
[Music]
That's the coolest.
Freeze-dried raw egg.
And this also has the consistency
of almost a meringue,
which is awesome.
So, can you freeze
dry a solid raw egg?
You can.
I'm not sure what
the purpose would be,
but you can do it.
Now, this was just
our raw egg cracked in a bowl,
and then left.
Now, I'm going to leave
this one for last
because I actually want to try
a few experiments with this.
I want to see
if you can reconstitute a raw
freeze dried egg for cooking,
so we'll set this one aside.
And we're going to look at are
freeze-dried cooked eggs.
This one's probably
the funniest to me.
A hard-boiled freeze dried egg.
Like the other
ones are awesome,
because yeah...
That, that weighs nothing.
This is just over easy hard egg.
[Music]
They're not terrible.
That's still edible.
I don't know
if you'd ever want egg crackers,
but you can do it.
And I'm actually very curious
about the scrambled eggs,
because supposedly,
you can reconstitute those.
You throw them in the skillet
with some hot water,
and you should be able
to bring them back to life.
So I want to see.
But just as comparison,
these are two eggs
that I made this morning,
and these are freeze dried ones.
So if you compare these,
as far as looks go,
they haven't changed nearly
as much as some other foods
that we've made in the past
in this freeze dryer.
[Music]
All right. So everything that's
on this tray has been cooked.
So even though it's
been freeze-dried
or anything like that,
these are all technically safe.
So an egg that was cooked
about 10 minutes ago...
[Music]
Regular cook egg.
This monstrosity.
[Music]
Well, it fell apart.
It's just crumble.
I can't even pick that up.
As far as taste goes,
it definitely tastes different.
It's hard to put
your finger on why.
[Music]
I'd almost say it has more
flavor, which is interesting,
because in the past,
we've noticed that things
in the freeze dryer,
if you try
and reconstitute them,
lose a lot of flavor,
but even before that,
this has a lot more flavor going
in than I would have expected.
Let's go to hard boiled.
[Music]
It is not wanting
to stay together.
Oh, okay.
That's also interesting.
The egg white is
just flaking apart.
But the egg yolk in this
is very resistant.
[Music]
Nope.
Okay, everything else is fine.
I do not recommend
freeze-drying hard-boiled eggs.
The center is still frozen.
But the taste is definitely off.
That's a little bit strange.
Let's see if we can bring those
scrambled eggs back to life,
and then I'm curious
about that raw egg.
Supposedly, you can use raw eggs
that have been freeze
drying in cooking,
just like you can fresh eggs.
So I want to try that.
Just like reconstituting
anything, we're gonna add
a little bit of water,
see if we can turn
that into egg.
[Music]
They're getting sort
of squishy again.
[Music]
After everything
that we've tried in
our Harvest Right freeze dryer,
this is the best thing
that's turned out.
This actually tastes just
like scrambled eggs.
That is awesome
that you can do that.
All right, let's put
this to the test.
We're going to have equal
ingredients for our mug cakes,
toss in one freeze dried egg,
one raw egg,
and see what happens.
[Music]
So 10 tablespoons
of your cake mix.
For mug cakes,
you don't really need
to be that specific.
[Music]
Teaspoon of vegetable oil.
Add our eggs.
Now, for our raw egg,
we are going to remove the yolk
because we did
that for the freeze dried egg.
[Music]
Seems right.
And then for water,
I just add water until you
get a cake batter consistency.
So obviously, we're going
to need more water
in our freeze dried egg,
but the result
should be the same.
Much less water in this one.
[Music]
All right, so the first thing
that I'm noticing is
while they have
the same consistency,
mostly, their water content
seems to be about the same now.
Our one with the freeze-dried
eggs is definitely less tacky,
less sticky, and I'm wondering
if that's going
to affect anything.
Regular egg cake mug.
[Music]
It's a little doughy on top,
but these mugs apparently
top out at about one minute
for our mug cakes.
All right, so we had
about the same amount.
You can already see how much
a mug cake just rises up.
So hopefully, we'll get the same
result with our powdered egg.
[Music]
That was about one minute.
So I'll do the same.
[Music]
Oh, wow, it actually looks
fluffier than our regular egg.
But they rose to almost
the exact same height.
They both have one giant bubble
right in the middle.
Taste test time.
Regular first.
[Music]
Cherry chip cake,
which is awesome.
Freeze dried egg, just powdered,
not even powdered well,
and tossed into a cake.
[Music]
Literally, no difference.
That is awesome.
You can freeze dry your eggs.
You don't have
to use the egg yolk.
You don't even have
to powderize it well,
and you can cook with it.
That is amazing.
I am thrilled.
Also, I have cake for lunch.
Can you freeze
dry eggs in any form?
Yes, you can.
Can you reconstitute them,
and use them in cooking?
You can do that too.
Should you freeze dry
all types of eggs?
Probably not.
Harvest Right, thank
you so much for letting
us use your freeze dryer
for these experiments.
Guys, if you want
to see anything else
super weird freeze-dried,
let us know
in the comments below.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you to our latest video,
and that box at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb in the middle
to subscribe to the club,
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.